i just want to mention it's a moment ago
i said i was browsing twitter and it's
because i was in a message that tucker
carlson was having a unique conversation
uh ladies and gentlemen i am going to
play for you this clip i just pulled up
tucker carlson some good news before we
go a little justice finally the twitter
account libs of tick tock just surpassed
a million followers on twitter it's
about a minute long i i grant you this
clip from tucker carlson it just aired
tonight some good news before we go a
little justice finally the twitter
account libs of tick tock just surpassed
a million followers on twitter now it
was just last week that the washington
post since reporter taylor lorenz tried
to destroy the person who runs that
account but it turns out a lot of people
actually want the account because they
want to know what their teachers are
doing in the classroom it's not an
attack on anybody it's called
transparency
so tim poole of youtube fame with the
help of the daily wires jeremy boring
just put up a billboard in times square
highlighting what the washington post
tried to do
to the founder of libs of tick tock and
you're seeing on your screen now of
course as predicted taylor loren says
she's the victim here of course
this billboard is so undeniably idiotic
it's hilarious but don't forget these
campaigns have a much darker and more
violent side i'm grateful to be the
newsroom that recognizes these bad faith
politically motivated attacks as a
strong security team so she exposes the
founder of libs with tick tock to
violence but when you say her name
you're a terrorist in other words stop
hurting me she says as she punches you
in the face these people
well this is what they were saying about
vagina right they were saying that um so
was it um
uh sagar and cernovich get contacted by
the washington post saying what was your
intention by including the name of the
twitter official in your reporting and
your first of all they're all commenting
on this political story that uh that she
apparently had broke down in tears
during one of the meetings so commenting
on that story and then having elon musk
respond to them somehow became them
attacking her last i actually looked
this up earlier today
and a lot of those websites it's hard to
tell when they do these estimates she's
worth anywhere between 30 and 70 million
dollars
wow 78 i have the numbers actually right
here yeah but there's each website has
like a different you know estimation of
it so it depends on which one you look
at so i'm giving the swath right this is
a major public figure who has major
control in the world who's worth tons of
money but
you can't talk about her because that's
an attack well walt from wallmine.com
she is has over 38 million dollars worth
of twitter stock uh or
stock's worth over 28 million she makes
8 million a year as chief legal officer
and secretary at twitter it's 7.9
million eight million a year jesus don't
you talk about it don't you talk about
her ian well she's about yeah she's
about to get fired and have a nice
package goodbye
maybe he'll keep her on but you're
harassing her wow the misogyny i know
hurray i only take issue with the things
she's done and said she's cool here's a
prediction
i think
if twitter really is allowed to become
an organic thing
the big story is going to be
how everything changes when you see
it reflect what people really think and
feel
instead of this balanced conversation as
maybe tim suggested
it's not so balanced and i'm not saying
all views shouldn't be heard they should
be heard but i think people will be
surprised how small some of this group
becomes
and how big other groups become that you
haven't heard much
from because they've been suppressed a
problem that comes up on social media
since the beginning it seems like is
that the most popular thing gets more
traction than everything else because it
goes up on trending and then they're
like what's that and then it just
snowballs things like crazy things can
snowball like the swastika hitler didn't
you know nothing that's true
always with unless you have social media
unless you have um like time like
chronological feeds because then you're
just seeing what just got posted by the
people you're following but people can
share
so share popular stuff right and then
when they do the more you share it the
more people see it across time you're
right like the most famous people get
free stuff like that makes it so weird
oh i mean look if you're rich the bank
gives you money if you're poor they take
it from you it's same with social media
attraction it's very weird it's almost
like physics
i mean look yeah i heard i've heard the
joke where you know they say when you're
rich the bank will give you money but
when you're poor they say you owe us
money and i'm like well here's why that
happens when you have very little money
in the account they have to pay to
maintain it
and so it's draining their you know
draining their uh money to run an
account for you that's not being
utilized enough so they charge you for
it it seems counterintuitive if you're
very wealthy you're giving them access
to capital for whatever it is they want
to do and the popular
posts on twitter are getting more
eyeballs on twitter so that's why they
want the popular stuff at the top
similar to having a crazy big big cycle
so that it's it's always that way
there's some attempt at raising things
up the problem is
twitter wasn't doing it twitter inverted
it twitter was deciding what was going
to be youtube is deciding for political
reasons
if everything was based off merit
i'll tell you
youtube would be a wacky place
all of the thumbnails would be big
tittied women because that's i'm not
trying to be crass that's literally what
it was
uh all of these big creators in the
early days of youtube realize that if i
want views the thumbnails gotta get
people to click on it well wasn't this
another thing where that was the
thumbnail but the video actually had
nothing to do with it exactly yeah or or
what they would do is they'd be like i'm
gonna comment on this video game story
but first yo we got this story about the
supermodel isn't she looking great yes
the supermodel did these things anyway
onto the video games that way they could
justify well i did talk about her
because youtube tried cracking down
saying okay you can't use thumbnails
that do not represent the video it's
causing us problems
so youtube slowly starts making rules to
try and deal with the insanity that is
this platform and eventually they say
okay the other problem we have is
people are just posting two minute clips
we need people to post long form stuff
so they make this algorithm that
promotes videos over 10 minutes videos
with high engagement rates and what did
they get they were hoping for game of
thrones they got culture wars
and they don't like it
then they realized hey wait a minute all
of these conservative anti-woke and
libertarian personalities are getting a
lot of traction because people like
their ideas
ban them
and they did this show was shadow banned
uh you could not google search it for a
year and a half
and then one day i mentioned on this
show i was like oh yeah google shadow
band it's like if you if you were to
google the title of one of our clips the
facebook version would come up and the
youtube would not
on google
that seems to make no sense and then one
day everyone's like tim they removed it
you can be searched again
there was a hit piece in the media
and then all of a sudden a wave of
youtubers who were deemed wrong thinkers
were purged from the recommendation
algorithm because someone just said i
don't like it i can't live that i'm like
a peacetime strategist i'm not a wartime
strategist but in my mind i think we
have to build a system where that can
never happen again but then i'm like
well in times of war you have to be able
to censor the enemy at least if you
don't the enemy's propaganda will
convince your people to kill you so you
that's what's i i honestly i think
chinese propaganda is destroying us
russia tried they overreact as to what
russia was actually doing but i think
china's actually way more successful and
the reality is
yeah we had an office of censorship in
world war ii because there were concerns
that journalists particularly would put
out information that would harm the war
effort
speaking of that i got this is amazing
life magazine from march 1944
which is i think it's 44 but it's a
magazine from
two months
three months before d-day
in the magazine they show all of the
american military power in the uk
it's fascinating they said the united
states is helping the uk in the event
germany may try to invade
only what was actually happening was the
u.s was preparing to storm the beaches
of normandy
stage d-day but they could not say that
in the press so in this magazine at the
time they're like we're here with our
military to protect britain
fake news so it was fake news so i mean
this is actually something i studied
when i was in the ic i went through
classes on this um they call it denial
and deception operations so
germany knew that there was an invasion
coming and it was going to be the
americans the question was where would
the origin where would the
invasion come from
and
they conducted so
many deception operations because they
knew
that the germans had spies throughout
europe so what did they do
they knew that they sent patton to
europe because they knew patton they
sent him to the uk because they knew
that the germans would be watching him
but where do they send him
they don't send him across from normandy
they send him to dover now dover is
directly across from calais this is the
the shortest point between on the
english channel this is actually where
the channel tunnel is because it's the
shortest point normandy is where the
invasion actually was it's not where
you'd expect
they send patton over to dover what do
they do
they get
soldiers and they make fake uniform
patches for them depicting fake units
they have these soldiers go into town
and pretend that there's a massive
buildup they start running hotel rooms
they start buying food they start
sending messages they're going all
throughout town and they act as if
they're all members of various units
that are there in the town and yet none
of it's real so the german high command
is getting all these reports back saying
hey there's a ton of stuff going on in
cali you know right across from calais
from this place called dover we think
it's coming what do the germans do
they realize that they can't put all
their eggs in one basket they split the
forces along the north atlantic wall
from normandy and calais the deception
and there's there's way more to it than
this there's so much to get into they
actually
they used a dead body at one point and
they put like fake documents the british
did this right they put fake documents
in the body drop him off of the rock of
gibraltar he washes up on spain the
spanish find the guy they hand him to
the german embassy they say look we've
got these documents see there you know
we know all about this invasion it's
coming and then that makes its way up
hitler
splits the forces
the deception operation was so extensive
that even after d-day
they kept the forces split because they
still thought another invasion was going
to be coming they thought normandy
was a faint they thought that was the
decoy and an even bigger one was still
coming wow it's it's incredible this is
one of the greatest military deception
operations that you're talking about
there that's ever been conducted
you think if hitler wasn't a meth head
that he would have taken the troops out
of calais
well no i mean i think it's game theory
right i think it's game theory that if
you don't have keep in mind this isn't
an age of satellites and
you know thermal uh you know resonance
imaging ir flea or any drones etc so you
really don't know so you're going based
off of you know you've got the enigma
machine uh to send encrypted messages
but that's already broken right um even
though he didn't know that um and then
you've got these human human
intelligence reports so game theory
suggests that if you've got what appears
to be credible information of two
invasion forces you've got to prepare
for both
all right
well how about the theory that
and i understand some of this
information has to be controlled
who do you trust to control do you trust
your own government to be doing the
right thing during times of war no
and i'm going back to cnn i worked there
back when it was a news organization in
1990. wow long time ago
and gulf war one was happening actually
1989 i think it was around august when
iraq invaded kuwait
and we spent three years i think doing
great coverage
but listening to almost every day saddam
hussein's press guy
give his view
and i think it would be
you know not accurate to say that the
people watching cnn were convinced by
iraq's press guy to take iraq's
viewpoint
they weren't but it was valuable to see
how they were portraying their side and
their viewpoint i think we have a right
to see it i think it's inform it informs
us to see and hear that
and the notion that i've heard lately
that we shouldn't even hear
certain viewpoints or enemies or we
wouldn't want to hear from hitler i'd
want to hear from hitler
i'm not saying that i would want to
believe what hitler says i would love to
hear his justifications and his
explanations i don't think that should
be banned
i mean maybe there's some stuff that
should be yeah the cuties the argument
is cuties like it's so vile that in
order to just to see it is the
corruption so like just to listen to
joseph goebbels
speak about the jews was like enough to
be have a a weak mind corrupted by it so
they're like some people can handle it
like you are able to look at it
logically
cuties actually had little girls doing
that that is that's actually excellent
and you could say that what joseph
goebbels was doing was you know vile the
way he was dehumanizing people nazis
literally no but cuties don't speak
people cuties wasn't speech that's
that's completely different i don't know
i think a movie could be considered a
form of sound no that's actual what
about an internet video of you talking
about speech hold on yes in the film
they took little girls these are real
human beings and they had them perform
lewd dances for an extended period of
time and be trained to do it that is not
speech
oh uh well self-expression i don't know
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
an adult human male takes a little girl
into a back room and teaches her
extensive lewd dancing so are you are
you speaking are you suggesting that
imagery is not a form of speech what are
you talking about because if someone
posts a picture on twitter let's slow
down again
a man
several of them took little girls into a
room to teach them lewd sexualized
dancing wait wait don't forget they were
they were paid and they were paid to do
it
that is not speech yeah but i'm not
talking about that i'm talking about the
trail of the movie right we are and
that's the problem
ian i know you are that's not what i
brought up cuties for it's not about
that you cannot
sexually abuse children to make a piece
of speech well showing the movie is not
the abuse they accept children
this is this comes up in the child porn
arguments and this was in kataji brown
jackson stuff is that every time you
show the image every time another person
sees it the child is then re-exploited
okay so that that argument could be
taken to joseph goebbels talking about
the dehumanization of jews every time
you listen to him say that he's doing
something
that's that's more than speech no no no
no ian yeah this is the argument anyway
you don't understand
if you go out
and you say
murder is wrong that's speech
okay if you go out
film yourself killing someone and then
show the video saying that was wrong
what i did it's like okay that that
video is a is a is a depiction of
someone being murdered of you committing
a crime that is not speech
that is that is journalistic integrity
you as a journalist saw a video of me
killing someone and showed people you
wouldn't be on the hook that's not we're
talking about i'm talking about other
people showing video that might be
harmful to the mind you you need to i
don't know if you need to censor it but
if you don't the difference between
really gerbils and cuties is that
first of all he was a nazi and the nazis
did those things but if you're referring
to someone who is advocating for
genocide
the question is are they actively
participating in doing it or just
expressing themselves when you're
talking about cuties you're talking
people people who actively participated
in exploiting little girls so talk about
genocide just talking about it versus
doing it well how about this then how
about let's let's take it out of the
abstract facebook said that in certain
areas of europe because of the russia
ukraine conflict right now they are
going to take off their normal ban on
calls for violence as long as you're
calling for violence up to and including
murder of
anyone of russian ethnicity yeah yeah
these are weapons these social media
networks are weapons so they're
basically saying that no i don't know
whether or not that includes genocide
but that certainly sounds like genocide
right if you're you know basing this on
you know someone's ethnicity so facebook
has come out and said we will agree with
this and we will allow this under the
circumstances so correct me if i'm wrong
but i think that alluding to genocide is
legal under for our free speech laws but
as long as it's not an imminent threat
like on wednesday at 2 p.m go do that
then you're not inciting anything yeah
are you just saying i want them to be
gone yep that i could believe is legal
it is legal speech so on twitter if that
goes up and then it gets a million
retweets and then all these people are
like yeah i think that too you're
creating a dangerous precedent well this
was in the the the ted talk that that um
that musk was doing the guy interviewing
him said you know some hate speech is
legal right i hate broccoli
right you know i hate ice cream
whatever right like you're allowed to
say that you hate certain things you
take the emotion out of it so elon i
don't think will he says he's a free
speech absolutist but i don't think
twitter will be absolutely free speech
that's absurd there's nothing that's not
going to be allowed and you going on
twitter and advocating for genocide i do
not believe elon will allow
he's going to be like no because you're
calling for violence and it's just it's
on the line but what happens then when
it comes into the
uh the israel-palestine question
because palestinians constantly say that
they want to see the country of israel
wiped off the map from the front river
to the sea yeah right and then and
prominent blue czech journalists have
said this yes i was told that that was a
misintermis translation that they
actually want to
legally remove the borders and undo the
country's formation not kill the people
and destroy it all this is what haman
i think that's his name with the
president of iran for a while was saying
i want israel wiped off the map but he
was saying that he wants it literally
redrawn and taken away because it was
done unjustly not that he wanted to kill
them but the media was like oh he wants
some wipes out now let's make him a
villain and say he wants to hurt people
i don't i don't think there's any point
in trying to dissect the
israel-palestine conflict in the span of
a few minutes too much you know of
course there's going to be a guy who
says this is what we really mean rest
assured uh the alcazam brigades are not
agreeing with that assessment and when
they fire a rocket out of a children's
hospital at civilians in israel it's
because they want to wipe them out not
just that out of
the basement of the ap's headquarters
right yeah where they were at where they
were operating and the ap had an office
in gaza city co-located with one of
these rocket bases and never once
reported on it
these are tough questions some of these
are hard calls
but let's go back to the absurdity of
what's become with social media and the
internet
you brought up gerbils
one of the only things i know i was
banned for on facebook
was fairly recently i posted a garbles
quote that simply said something like
with no context
it is quite possible knowing the
psychology of the audience to convince
people that a square is in fact a circle
that could mean anything it could be a
criticism
it could be aimed i knew what i was
aiming it as but i simply did a historic
quote right and i got pulled down my
account
and i thought it was a mistake and there
was no way to appeal and i kept checking
back and a week later i'm back up and i
said
there must have been some mistake all i
did was quote historically hitler's
propaganda saying
that people can be convinced i got
banned again i was gone for another 10
days so you can't even
say something like that tim how many
lights are there in this room
five
little lights for four
four lights
yeah so what i do is i like to tweet
under no pretext
shall the right of the people shall the
right of the people to keep and bear
arms be infringed it must be frustrated
by force if necessary
and that's from um
hold on uh carl miss jeff remarks that
get you banned well i i feel like if you
quote the second amendment you might but
if you quote marx you probably won't so
karl marx has the quote under no pretext
shall the workers relinquish the right
to bear arms
it should be frustrating any any
attempts to take this you know weapons
from the people chairman mao political
power grows in the barrel of a gun yeah
so my point is i mix the together and
i'm like hey look it's not left to right
it's liberty you know but i guess the
authoritarians say that too and then
take your guns once they gain power
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and we'll see you all there
you